there's no denying it director Andy
machetes 2017 adaptation of Stephen
King's it was 50 shades of freaky well
prepare for things to get scarier
bloodier and way more traumatizing in
the film's upcoming sequel it's chapter
2 it's just been confirmed that two
extremely controversial aspects of Kings
1986 novel have made it into the film
spoilers ahead speaking to The Hollywood
Reporter screenwriter Gary Doberman
revealed that it's chapter 2 will
include one of the most haunting scenes
in the book a horrific hate crime
against a young gay man named Adrian
melon who will be portrayed by actor
writer and director Xavier Dillon in the
book Mellon becomes a victim of a savage
beating at the hands of three homophobic
teenagers who throw him over a bridge
then he's subsequently murdered by penny
wise a dancing clown this subplot was
conspicuously absent from the 1990
television adaptation of it but the
creative team behind the upcoming film
thought it was important to include
Milan's story as Doberman explained to
The Hollywood Reporter it's an iconic
scene in the book and one we wanted to
include in the movie it is the influence
of penny wise even while he is
hibernating and it's pure evil what
happens to Adrien these bullies working
through penny wise was important for us
to show another contentious aspect of
King's novel as the plight of adult
Beverly Marsh portrayed by Jessica
Chastain the second part of King's novel
jumps ahead 27 years and we learned that
Marsh has become a domestic abuse victim
at the hands of her husband Tom Brogan
we now know this storyline is included
in its chapter two and the film closely
mirrors the events of the book as
Doberman explained the whole production
wanted to remain true to the original
novel it's safe to say that its sequel
will outdo the first installment on
every front the Obermann promises that
the film is definitely bloodier than the
first and is just too scary if not
scarier you sketti clearly agrees over a
year ago he warned fans that they should
prepare to be rocked to the core
claiming that it's going to be scarier
and more intense so bring your adult
diapers to the movie theaters two more
tidbits are sure to pique the interest
of any gore hound the film evidently
features a scene that's dolls in a
shocking amount of stage blood and petty
wise will reportedly be far more savage
this time around
Chastain described the bloody sequence
in an interview with Jimmy Fallon
there's a scene that someone said on set
that it's the most blood that's ever
been in a
horror film see in am innocent meanwhile
Pennywise actor bill skarsgård told
Entertainment Weekly of a creature has
only become stronger in the 27 years has
spent lying dormant in the dairy sewers
and whereas Pennywise was once
terrorizing the children for sports the
ghastly creature is now motivated by
revenge as skarsgård explains it fuels
hatred and anger towards the kids there
will be adults in this one so I think
there might be an even more vicious
Pennywise he's really going after him it
sounds like it chapter 2 is going to be
truly terrifying and the inclusion of
those two and settlings subplots from
the book will just make the film even
more upsetting see how everything plays
out when it's chapter 2 flows into
theatres on September 6th check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about it chapter
two are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]